follow length focus on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram hello everyone
Lange focus channel AOPA so Kyowa I want
to talk about something called
code-switching Gengo Ikeda Kyoto some
people are monolingual and speak just
one language other people are bilingual
or multilingual and speak more than one
language bilingual or multilingual
people sometimes switch back and forth
between two or more different languages
this is called code switching one
situation in which code switching is
common is within immigrant families for
example let's imagine a Russian family
moves from Russia to the United States
and the children grow up speaking
Russian as their native language but
they learn English outside of the home
when the children in that family speak
to their siblings they might code switch
between Russian and English another
situation in which code switching is
common is in certain countries where a
native language is spoken alongside a
former colonial language one example
that comes to mind is in India where
Hindi English code switching is common
and another example is in Philippines
where Tagalog English code switching is
common you may have seen my earlier
video on diglossia which means switching
between two different languages or two
different forms of a language in
different situations for example formal
versus informal situation code switching
is different in that people switch
languages in a single situation within a
single conversation and sometimes within
a single sentence code switching is
largely unpredictable and speakers often
impulsively switch languages without any
conscious choice in code switching one
language is the dominant language
normally the native language of the
group this is sometimes called the
matrix language and the additional
language is called the embedded language
the matrix language lays out the basis
for the communication and then
utterances from the additional language
are embedded into the matrix language
there are various reasons that people
might switch from their matrix language
to an embedded language number one
directive function people switch
languages to either include or exclude
other people from the conversation maybe
you want to tell secrets so you switch
to a language that people around you
don't understand or maybe the opposite
maybe you want to end the private
conversation and Riaan
age with the people around you so you
switch to a language that they do
understand number two expressive
function people include the embedded
language in order to express some part
of their identity
for example they want to show their
connection to a certain country or
culture and in some cases it might be an
expression of status through association
with a prestigious out-group number
three referential function someone who
is unable to express an idea easily in
one language switches to the other
language in order to express it more
easily this seems to be very common
among bilingual children and immigrant
families number four static function
sometimes the speaker switches languages
or repeats something in both languages
in order to emphasize it number five
metalinguistic function this is
reporting something in the other
language or commenting on something said
in the other language for example you're
speaking in Japanese but then you quote
a lyric from an English language song
without translating it maybe you say
something in the embedded language but
then you explain it or add further
commentary in the matrix language number
six poetic function the speaker says
certain words or makes jokes in the
embedded language for amusement or for
some kind of artistic purpose
code-switching
takes a few different forms here are
some of the main ones number one
inter sentential switching in which the
language switches for entire sentences
or clauses for example a bilingual
Spanish English speaker says sometimes
I'll start a sentence in English ET de
Meno en espanol number two intra
sentential switching in which the
speaker switches languages within the
clause or sentence boundary here's an
example from a bilingual English
Portuguese speakers speech I don't know
may you lugan si mundo this means I
don't know my place in this world
number three extra sentential or tag
switching a tag from one language is
inserted into an utterance in another
language for example a bilingual English
Japanese speaker might say it's a good
movie they show meaning it's a good
movie right let's look at a couple of
cases of code switching the first one is
from the Indian movie the three idiots
the matrix language is Hindi and the
embedded language is English the
background to the scene is that the
director of the university is welcoming
the incoming freshmen
students don't forget you can stylize
image a lot applications are then
automated james dojo select a little bit
you you now let's take a look at the
sentence we just heard the sentence
means don't forget i seee receives four
hundred thousand applications a year and
of those only two hundred are selected
you the first Clause of this sentence
don't forget is in English this is inter
sentential code switching because the
switching occurs at the clause boundary
this is probably done to draw attention
to the phrase which is the static
function applications is also in English
switching within the clause or sentence
boundaries I suspect that this words in
English because it's referring to
college applications and words related
to academic affairs are probably said
very frequently in English select is
also in english this is intra sentential
switching again the speaker or the
scriptwriters probably chose to save
this word in English in order to
emphasize the importance of this action
of selecting the freshman students and
of course you is in English this is
inter sentential because it occurs at
the collage boundary this word was
probably set apart and said in English
in order to emphasize the selection of
these particular students so again
that's the static function in general
the speaker in this scene might be using
English because he's the director of a
university and English is seen as an
integral part of academic life let's
look at a second example this time from
the Filipino movie My Baby Love now the
background to the scene is that the
young woman's father and the young man's
aunts have started dating each other
let's take a look at the whole scene
first
so okay numbers here you that mom okay
course not
laughing personal affair excuse me I'm
gangadharam amico Vanessa viene una Mesa
Grana Padano Miko so antipodean day
well mash maganda a monocle well my
baton antico el mas Lagonda Allah Miko
funny emphasize I already know Maya
Angelou parsad article is that if you
want to be here and be good at least we
agreed on something I have to go another
100 by now let's look at a few parts of
that scene again and break them down so
our numbers are you that mom all right
course not talking personal affair
excuse me
under a bandana mommy cool here we see
intro sentential switching with English
phrases embedded into a tagalog sentence
in her reply I think the woman switches
to English to emphasize certain points
the main message of a reply that her
mother is beautiful is in Tagalog but
this is an emotional conversation and
the English phrases draw attention to
how she's feeling
so honey begins a being voila this
acronym mother down we go
so auntie vaunette well math maganda are
Mamiko here we see extra sentential
switching or tag switching the
interjection well is in English but the
rest of the sentence is in Tagalog well
is a word that often comes before a
correction of something the other person
has said she says it with some obvious
annoyance so again I think she is using
the English word to draw attention to
the fact that she's correcting this guy
well my baton auntie go hey Mulligan da
Allah Miko fine here we see the same
kind of tag switching with still that
word basically rejects the guy's
response and by doing it in English
she's drawing attention to that
rejection and besides I didn't want to
ask you about a sabbatical is that what
you wanted to hear the first sentence
here to begins with tag switching and
then she switches to English again for
the entire second sentence her second
sentence is spoken with some resentment
and I think it's said in English to
emphasize that any good at EC of reason
something the first interjection Eddie
good means good then and there's a kind
of vindictive expression then in the
second sentence the guy speaks entirely
in English I think this shows that he is
starting to lose his cool and get
annoyed making his speech more emphatic
I have to go in on a felony by in this
final comment from the woman we see
inter sentential switching and I think
she basically emphasizes the important
point by using English and D emphasizes
the less important point by using
Tagalog the important point is that
she's leaving and the reason for leaving
is unimportant and she may even want it
to be obvious that the reason is a
made-up excuse she quickly rushes
through her excuse into Gallo's almost
too quickly to even understand this kind
of code switching using basically 50%
English and 50% Tagalog is quite common
in the Philippines especially amongst
middle-class and upper-class people the
reason for switching is not always
emotional like in that scene but it's
more often an expression of identity and
status code switching is very common in
certain bilingual or multilingual
environments and I hope that these
examples give you some insight into how
why it's used in certain situations the
question of the day for people who live
in a bilingual environment
do you often code switch between two
different languages tell us a little bit
about how and why you code switch be
sure to follow length focus on Facebook
Twitter and Instagram and once again I'd
like to say thank you to all of my
fantastic patreon supporters especially
these ones right here on the screen
thank you for watching and have a nice
day
[Music]
[Music]